After 50 years old
Do you need to hold onto the handrail
to feel safe when going up the stairs?
The knees
also make a clicking sound
This is actually a warning sign
that your muscle mass is gradually decreasing
What should eat
to increase muscle mass
Doctor, the five foods you asked me to buy last time
I bought it!
5 Muscle-Building Foods You Can Buy
at the Supermarket
It helps you build muscle strength
saves you money, and makes walking easier
Knees are stronger
I'll tell you right away
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
Let's take a look.
What good foods are available in supermarkets?
Okay, let's take a look.
Yes, this is a canned food.
There is a type of meat
and yogurt
firm tofu
and the eggs I bought
Let me start with the first one.
It's a super affordable muscle-building product.
Eat less of these two types of eggs
You can buy tea eggs
and iron eggs at the supermarket, right?
A small egg
weighs only about 50 grams
It only costs about
ten NT dollars
It contains a full 7 grams
of protein
Is that considered a lot of protein?
How much protein do we need to eat each day?
We adults
The recommended daily protein intake
is approximately 0.8 grams per kilogram
of body weight
If you weigh 50 kilograms
That requires 40 grams of protein per day.
If you are
mature people over 65 years old
need more protein
which should be 1 to 1.2 times your body weight in grams
So you eat an egg
This can provide 1/4
of the daily protein requirement
So, according to this calculation...
It seems like four are enough
But can't just eat eggs, okay?
Isn't this an incredibly good value for money?
Yes, that seems to be the case.
Some people don't like egg yolks
It's such a pity.
All the nutrients in an egg
are hidden in the yolk
Egg yolks contain three nutrients
Choline can activate the brain
Make your work thinking clearer
A clearer mind
Lutein also helps protect the eyes.
Vitamin D also helps maintain bone health.
There was an old man
It's not that don't like egg yolks
it's that afraid to eat them
He gave all the egg yolks
to his son
The son mixed the egg yolk into the white rice.
The old man's mouth watered.
Why is he afraid to eat?
I guess he's worried about his cholesterol being too high.
Yes, many people are like that.
Did you know that my dad
stopped eating egg yolks
after he turned 40
You must be wondering
I have high blood pressure, high cholesterol, and high blood sugar.
How many eggs can I eat a day?
If you have high blood pressure, high blood sugar, or high cholesterol
Or chronic kidney disease
One per day
Healthy people can eat one or two.
Don't exceed three!
There are two kinds of eggs
1. Do not eat undercooked eggs.
2. Egg that has been braised for too long
You need to be careful about some things.
What happens if you eat an undercooked egg?
May carry Salmonella
It causes vomiting and diarrhea.
Even more serious
septicemia
That's terrifying!
My friend really loves raw eggs!
I want to tell him
really shouldn't eat too much.
It's even better not to eat it.
Oh, there's a second one.
Eggs that have been braised for too long should be eaten sparingly.
Marinated eggs are marinated for a long time.
Added a lot of sauces and seasonings
The sodium content in it
Higher than a boiled egg
Moreover
the protein structure has already denatured
Nutrient loss
Eating this frequently may cause hair loss
and dry skin.
ate eggs and drank soy milk for breakfast
Why feel weaker the more eat?
doctor, there was a grandmother in her sixties.
She eats breakfast
Two boiled eggs and soy milk
It was thought to improve sarcopenia
As a result
the feeling of weakness did not improve
It's getting weaker and weaker
Why is this happening?
The principle is very simple
If you only eat protein,
you lack energy sources
Like carbohydrates
Carbohydrates are the same as carbohydrates, right?
The body will then burn protein
to provide energy
Instead of using it to build muscles
Protein is essential for building muscle.
Okay, you've used up all its energy.
Of course, muscles won't grow.
What's a good way to eat breakfast?
You can eat boiled eggs and soy milk.
Add a serving of whole grains
For example, a small piece of sweet potato
This helps proteins
be converted into muscle more efficiently
It activates the body's metabolic engine
allowing muscles to truly absorb nutrients
What kinds of protein foods do you usually eat
for breakfast?
Can you leave me a message?
Eating the right 3 types of soy products
can nourish both muscles and bones
Come , mothers!
Can you guess
which type of plant-based protein,legumes
has the highest protein content?
You have three seconds to think
3 2 1
Time's up
Soybeans have the highest protein
content among plant-based foods
Common soybeans include
Soybeans, black soybean, and edamame
When going to the supermarket
You can choose from these three
Pressed tofu, dried tofu, soy milk
How much protein do they contain?
If we calculate in 100 grams...
The Pressedtofu contains 8.5 grams
How much dried tofu is there?
100 grams of dried tofu
contains 17 grams of protein
That's equivalent to 2.5 eggs
The protein content is excellent
Unsweetened soy milk
Calculated per 100 milligrams
It contains 3.6 grams of protein
The content of these three proteins
They're all pretty good
Let me tell you a little secret
Pressedtofu is better for bones than soft tofu
because
Some calcium carbonate
is added during the production of firm tofu
Therefore, it contains a lot of calcium
You eat Pressedtofu
It's a great way to boost muscle strength and bone health
killing two birds with one stone
If you are over 50 years old
Feeling weak in hands and feet
Or you are a vegetarian.
Limited protein sources
When going to a buffet snack shop
Dried tofu and Pressed tofu
Choose these two
That sounds like
It's pretty good
When I go to a braised food shop
I also order Hundred Layer Tofu, fried bean curd sheets, and dried flower
Can they also supplement protein?
It contains protein.
But have you noticed?
They smell especially good
yse
That's because
Is it because it's been processed or deep-fried
It absorbs a lot of oil
The calorie content also increases accordingly
It's okay to eat it occasionally
But it shouldn't be eaten frequently or every day
Otherwise, before you get enough protein
you'll gain weight and become stronger
You'll become a chubby girl!
ok
Even with a tight budget, you still need to take care of your muscles
Get protein from just one can
If you are over 40
feel like every time squat down
It feels like standing up
is slower now
To maintain muscle mass
You should eat more fish and chicken breast.
Let's start with the first type of fish.
Fish muscle fibers are relatively short.
After biting it, you eat it.
It is relatively easy for the body to digest and absorb.
For people our age
It is very friendly
It can also increase EPA and DHA
Protect cardiovascular and brain health
I'm telling you
There is a product made from fish meat
It's so cheap it's often overlooked
What is it?
It's canned tuna
It's a great product for saving money.
Did you know
that my income wasn't high when I was studying in the US?
Just add some salt and sugar to the canned tuna
Stir-fry it. Stir-fry it until what?
Stir-fry it until it becomes fish floss
It really tastes good
really miss the canned tuna
from back then
What is the protein content?
A can of boiled tuna
After draining
it weighs approximately 140 grams
This jar contains
about 30 grams of protein
This is equivalent to almost replenishing the protein
you need for one meal
That's great!
People who want to control their weight and exercise
You can buy boiled tuna in cans.
A can costs only about 30 yuan.
It'll probably cost between 35 and 50 yuan.
You can mix it directly with rice.
Or spread on a sandwich
Add a little bit of vegetables
For example, corn, cucumbers, tomatoes, etc.
It was a wonderful meal!
Those whose wallets are flat at the end of the month
When you're almost broke
You can buy this canned tuna
to supplement your protein intake
Hey Xiaofen
I don't think you're living paycheck to paycheck.
No way! How could that be?
yes or no
How much canned tuna can you eat in a day?
Is changing the subject a good idea?
One can a day is enough.
Remember to pay attention
to its sodium content
Avoid consuming too much salt
Only then can you safely supplement your protein intake
Then the second type of meat
Everyone knows chicken breast
It's high in protein and low in fat.
Chicken is not just a source of protein
In Traditional Chinese Medicine
it also has the effect of tonifying the kidneys
Give your body more energy
You're so exhausted after get off work, like you've been drained of all your energy.
You can go to the supermarket
Buy this kind of chicken breast
or buy a bento box
Braised chicken legs, chicken rice, and chicken breast are all delicious to eat.
Chicken can help you
Accelerate recovery and reduce fatigue
It can also assist in muscle synthesis.
For the mature age group
It's really important
2 Secrets to Eating Yogurt
Build muscle and sleep well
If you take good care of your digestive system, your muscles will naturally grow well.
What is the relationship between the stomach and intestines and muscles?
The latest research findings
There is a correlation
between gut microbiota and muscle mass
Good bacteria in the gut
produce something called
short-chain fatty acids
It stimulates muscle synthesis and reduces inflammation.
You can eat yogurt like this normally
Replenishing beneficial bacteria helps build a strong foundation for muscles.
Master two secrets
First, choose yogurt with simple ingredients.
Second, eat 2 hours after a meal
or after exercise
What is simple yogurt?
When you buy yogurt
you can flip to the back
to check its ingredients
Select only
Choose yogurt
with only fresh milk and starter cultures
When I bought yogurt
see some added ingredients
Then there's the kind with whipped cream and sugar
And spices, and what else, right?
Try to eat as little of that as possible
Second, eat yogurt after exercise and after dinner
It has a better effect on muscle building.
Eat yogurt with a banana within 30 minutes
after exercising
Protein and carbohydrates
should be replenished in one go
Leucine in Yogurt
It can promote muscle growth
It can accelerate protein synthesis.
Eat it two or three hours
after dinner
Protein in yogurt heads
Provides amino acids at night
Reduce muscle breakdown
At the same time, its calcium and tryptophan
All of these can help you sleep better
For people over 40 who want to maintain muscle mass
but feel they aren't getting enough sleep
It's a very good choice
Dear fans
We have launched the membership channel
If you agree with my promotion of Traditional Chinese Medicine
The concept of taking care of one's own health
Small monthly donations are welcome.
It only costs the price of two cups of coffee!
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you by my side
Only then can we go further.
Thank you so much!